disloyal dirtbag and convicted felonious
lawyer michael cohen appeared on capitol
hill today to dance for the pleasure of
democrats desperate to cover up the
actual crimes they committed in their
effort to prevent Donald Trump from
becoming president and later to overturn
the election we will analyze the
pathetic but very entertaining showing
then a Democrat presidential candidate
makes slavery reparations a central
tenet of his campaign and a baby is born
seven years after her father died I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
that last story reminds me of this
famous line from The Odyssey where
Telemachus says about his father he says
it's a wise man who knows his own father
a lot of milk men walking around the
earth for all of human history but the
story that that story about the baby
being born seven years after her father
died is pretty bizarre I don't think it
has to do with milkman it has to do with
bizarre bioethics and questions of
designer babies we'll get to all of that
obviously we got to get through the
Michael Cohen testimony which was just
such a little treat this morning but
first let's make some money honey with
purple mattress you know I love purple
you know I am a proselytizer of purple
purple mattress is unlike any mattress
you've ever slept on it is not an
innerspring it's not quite a memory foam
there's this unique technology that is
both firm and soft at the same time
developed by a rocket scientist I was
very skeptical of this I actually when
they gave me a mattress I didn't even
want to get rid of my old mattress I
said I don't know if I get rid of my old
mattress I don't like this it's kind of
weird it's kind of new I don't know I
try it out for one night one night is
all it took it is the best mattress I've
ever slept on I immediately just threw
out my old mattress you know totally got
rid of it
it is fabulous I love it I have been
telling everybody to get this thing
especially I used to have a lot of back
pain and sleep problems I sleep like a
little baby it is so good there is a 100
night risk-free trial if you're not
fully satisfied you can return it for a
full refund you won't want to return it
back by 10-year warranty free shipping
and returns free in-home set up an old
mattress removal
you're gonna love purple right now
you'll get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress in addition to
the great gifts they're offering
site-wide if you text kotha facio v fe
fe two eight four eight eight eight
that's the only way to get this free
pillow cough fi co v fe fe two eight
four eight eight eight text co v fe fe 8
2 8 4 8 8 8 message and data rates apply
Michael Cohen dirtbag lawyer convicted
an admitted liar I went to Capitol Hill
today to testify to Congress which he
previously had lied to the GOP came out
with a little ad before this happened
you'll remember Michael Cohen used to
say I love Trump
I'll take a bullet for Trump I'll never
turn on Trump now he goes to Capitol
Hill to say the Trump is a liar and a
racist and a cheater and at every sorts
of terrible thing so in advance of this
ridiculous testimony that has zero
credibility the GOP released an
advertisement that just contrasted well
Michael Cohen is saying with his past
statements now I want to tell you about
the real Donald Trump he's really a he's
a unifier the words the media should be
using to describe mr. Trump are generous
he's going to do everything that he
promised he's gonna bring success and
he's gonna make America great
compassionate principled Donald Trump
speaks from the heart and pathetic kind
he's gonna stay true to who he is he's
gonna be an amazing president humble
honest and genuine mr. Trump's memory is
fantastic and I've never come across the
situation where mr. Trump has said
something that's act that's not accurate
well Donald Trump wants to do is make
this country great again says have fun
in prison there at the end I'm just sort
of smelling those Michael Cohen tears
that dirty disloyal rat this is a great
ad people are mocking this ad right now
because Michael Kohn was the personal
lawyer to Donald Trump they're saying
man if this guy is such a dirtbag liar
if he's obviously flipped so
significantly why did Trump hire him
doesn't show a lot of good judgment why
did the RNC put him on their board make
I think he was deputy finance chairman
why did they do that this ad actually
requires humility and it demonstrates
humility on the part of the GOP it's an
ad that admits that Donald Trump hired
Fredo to play Michael Tom Hagen rather
to play the smart
put-together lawyer ends up hiring this
buffoon it admits that the RNC hired a
schmuck to be its deputy finance
chairman it's worth it it's worth
admitting all of that this is in the old
school before Donald Trump before
reality TV
before social media really took over
politics to the degree that they have in
the old school you would never admit
that kind of mistake you would never
admit poor judgment you would never
admit that this guy you shouldn't have
hired him in the first place you would
just try to make the changing facts fit
your narrative and it would really
hamper how you could respond to events
in this new school it's a it's the break
china school of thought it's the China I
mean China like the porcelain eye it's
the break China school of thought it
says yep yeah we shouldn't hire to meet
you schmuck he's a bad guy look what he
said though look at this you're reacting
in real-time it gives you far greater
dexterity it gives you far greater
leverage in politics their word me yeah
Cohen flipped go and flip that doesn't
mean that he's honest now by the way
that's what the left is trying to say
they're saying Cohen used to be really
loyal to Trump and he said all these
things that relies but now he's being
honest we don't know that we have no
reason to believe that all we know is
he's disloyal this is why we was kind of
going back and forth with Ben over this
ben said you can't call him a rat and a
liar a rat means you know you're you're
snitching on your old employer but if
you're snitching and you're angry with
him for telling the truth and you can't
be angry with him for lying know what
what is meant by a rat is that he's
disloyal now maybe he's telling some
truth maybe he's telling some lies
nobody can lie all the time we're tell
the truth all the time for that matter
people are more complicated than that
certainly these kind of guys are more
complicated than that so yeah he's
disloyal and apparently he's incompetent
and he's a liar okay so what is this
today this hearing today is pure
political theater it's political theater
to detract distract rather from two
things this hanoi summit with kim
jong-un the second summit with North
Korea to try to denuclearize the
peninsula and it's to distract from the
fact that Democrats have come up empty
on Russia they're come up empty Senate
Intelligence investigation turned up
nothing that's according to Republicans
and Democrats so far Bob Muller has
turned up nothing
800-page manifold report turned up
nothing no clue
between Trump and Russia so they have to
distract by dragging Michael Cohen
before Congress Jim Jordan makes this
point very clear
I moved the table chairman to a second
mr. chairman yeah mr. chairman I was
asking to be recognized before the
motion vote is so enabling the motion
you know who had this material before
all the membranes the committee with me
CNN had it before voted it had the exert
before we did young well the vote is one
tabling the motion to postpone CNN had
the material before the committee did
that's what you and Jim Jordan gets that
right in there at the beginning to make
it clear this is not some normal
balanced hearing this is not to get any
pressing or urgent information this was
political theater set up by the
Democrats set up with their rat Judas
Michael Cohen and set up with the help
of the propaganda arm of the Democrat
Party which is called CNN CNN had
advance notice of all of these documents
knowing all of that you've got a major
credibility problem for the first time
ever a man who is convicted of lying to
Congress is now testifying before
Congress does that make a lot of sense
doesn't seem to make a lot of sense and
they're saying but he's not lying now
it's like they're a victim of fraud who
cuts a con man another check it's like
it's like an abused spouse who says no
no he's changed he's jaded he hasn't
changed they don't change even Michael
Cohen admits this credibility problem a
free agent that was reporting back to
the president what he had done correct
he frequently reached out to mr. Trump
and mr. Trump was very happy to take his
calls it was free service hmm
Roger stone says he never spoke with mr.
Trump about WikiLeaks how can we
corroborate what you are saying I don't
know oh that's pretty rough so in all of
those testimony says yeah and stone
Roger stone was talking of WikiLeaks
which is really a front for the Russians
and
then they called Trump and Trump took
the call and yeah yeah yeah
so Debbie wasserman-schultz she's so
excited whoo yes and how can we
corroborate what you're saying mr. Cohen
oh I don't know
I don't think they expected that answer
that he can't corroborate any of this
and you see it throughout the whole
testimony the the whole testimony he
makes these outrageous claims and really
they're just insults they're not even
that one was a a particular claim that
he can't defend but mostly it's just
insults just merging his character he's
a racist he's a vist he's of attaced and
say okay how can we corroborate his
honor Michael Cohen back when he was
Trump's flack couldn't corroborate those
right he said Donald Trump is the best
memory of anyone I've ever met he's the
most dignified man he has the most
integrity is the greatest guy that ever
walked the earth now he couldn't
corroborate that either and now because
he's the same guy because he's the same
lying dirtbag he's always been you can't
corroborate this he's just saying what
people want to hear he's just dancing
for the Democrats now he used to dance
for Trump now he dances for the
Democrats to try to limit his time in
prison to try to get a little public
sympathy so let's go through these
assertions these are these claims that
Michael Cohen is making in his testimony
because that what the Democrats are
relying on is that it's just gonna be
this cloud of fraud deception collusion
and nobody's gonna look into the
specifics let's look into the specifics
let's knock everyone down first specific
first claim from Michael Cohen Donald
Trump never really wanted to be
President he never expected to be
President he didn't want it this is one
of the main Democrat attack lines on
Trump he was only ever after his own
personal advancement making more money
building more hotels getting his name
out there branding that's all he was
interested in he never wanted to be
President never thought he was gonna be
President heck he might have been upset
when he won the presidency because it
hampered his own business career Michael
Cohen opens his testimony with this line
never in a million years did I imagine
when I accepted a job in
seven to work for Donald Trump that he
would one day run for the presidency to
launch a campaign on a platform of hate
and intolerance
okay hate and then he goes on his
hateful he's bigoted he's this is that
never did I imagine when I took a job
for Trump in 2007 the Trump would run
for president well
Donald Trump showed interest in running
for president in the 1980s he went up to
New Hampshire in the 1980s to talk to
potentially run for president he then
actually started to run for president in
1999 for the 2000 election eight years
before Michael Cohen started working for
Trump so either Michael Cullen is the
stupidest most oblivious man on earth or
he's lying it's actually not an
either/or I guess it could be both never
imagined he'd run for president no
nobody did who could imagine I mean what
a crazy thought that Donald Trump the
man who's been interested in running for
president and expressed as much since
the 80s would actually run for president
crazy right but then there's another
line he goes right back into it and he
said no no this is really what the
campaign was gonna be will show that one
second but first let's make a little
money with with a new sponsor a terrific
sponsor you know our friend Mike Rowe we
all love Mike Rowe if you're looking for
more great podcasts to listen to but
you're short on time you have got to
check out the way I heard it with Mike
Rowe this podcast gives a unique take on
American history it explores everything
from pop culture to politics actors to
athletes history to Hollywood and each
episode is 10 minutes or less it has a
very Reaganesque quality to it people
don't remember this but Reagan used to
have like a five-minute radio hit and it
would happen however many times a week
and he would tell these stories they
would always relate to politics or
American history or something like that
and they were really good really well
formed episodes this micro podcast
reminds me of this to a tea row has that
total stage presence that Reagan asked
stage presence the timing the topic it's
just fabulous it's stories for the
curious mind with the short attention
span it's fabulous
it's a also
reminiscent of the late Paul Harvey's
the rest of the story it's a short
mystery about a famous person or event
you know filled with surprising facts
you don't know it's America's number one
short form podcast downloaded more than
87 million times really really good I
loved I don't want to spoil it but
there's a great a great one about a
president who wanted to make America
great again and how it split a family
right up until the end go to micro comm
slash podcast today listen and subscribe
to the way I heard it mi ke
ro WM / podcast micro dot-com / podcast
+ micros just a great guy we like him
so this is the line Donald no one could
imagine Donald Trump wanted to be
President even though he's wanted to be
President for at least 30 or 40 years
now and looked Trump himself never
wanted it never expected it Trump is a
man who ran for office to make his brand
great not to make our country great he
had no desire or intention to leave this
nation only to market himself and to
build his wealth and power mr. Trump
would often say this campaign was going
to be the greatest infomercial in
political history he never expected to
win the primary he never expected to win
the general election the campaign for
him was always a marketing opportunity
all right no uncertain terms Donald
Trump never desired or intended to be
President all it was was a personal
marketing opportunity this line of
attack would be the Moscow hotel line of
attack from Democrats
he was only running to build hotels all
over the world and get his name on
billboards no desire or intention to be
president that's Michael Cohen
testifying before Congress except the
only problem with this line of attack is
it contradicts the other Democrat line
of attack which is that Donald Trump
wanted to be President so bad he was so
ruthless that he was willing to do
anything to get it including conspiring
with a four
government committing crimes with the
foreign government not only does Michael
Cohen's line there contradict this other
Democrat attack it contradicts Michael
Cohen's own statement that he gives
later on in this testimony that Donald
Trump was willing to do anything to
become president sometime in the summer
of 2017
I read all over the media that there had
been a meeting in Trump Tower in June of
2016 involving Don jr.
and others from the campaign with
Russians including a representative of
the Russian government and an email
setting up the meeting with the subject
line dirt on Hillary Clinton something
clicked in my mind I remembered being in
a room with mr. Trump probably in early
June of 2016 when something peculiar
happened Don Trump jr. came into the
room and walked behind his father's desk
which in and of itself was unusual
people didn't just walk behind mr.
Trump's desk to talk to him and I recall
Don jr. leave leaning over to his father
and speaking in a low voice which I
could clearly hear and saying the
meeting is all set and I remember mr.
Trump saying okay good let me know okay
there you have it Donald Trump set up an
elaborate back-channel with Vladimir
Putin to fix the 2016 election he was
personally apprised of these high-level
meetings with Russian officials so that
means not only did he desire to win but
he would have expected to win right
because he's cheating he ends up
cheating with no less an adversary than
the government of Russia to fix the 2016
election you can't have both of these
things you can't have Donald Trump never
desired or intended to be President and
Donald Trump both desired and intended
to be president so much that he cheated
fixed the election with Russia and
therefore expect
to be present you can't have that those
don't both work so why would Michael
Cohen say it Michael Cohen is throwing
spaghetti at the wall he's not here to
tell the truth he's not here because
he's now reformed he's seen the light
no Michael Cohen is trying to garner
public sympathy probably wants to get
out of jail a little earlier than he's
supposed to because he's a broken weak
man who has betrayed his benefactor
that's what it is
there's no I don't understand what the
other explanation would be this is what
happens when you get the squeeze put on
you is people just start saying anything
even if the things contradict themselves
which I've done right here so okay now
Michael Cohen has even less credibility
than he had when he started because
somewhere in there he's lying he'd not
he didn't only lie in the last
congressional testimony lies in this one
one of those conflicting statements has
to be a lie so next up Donald Trump is a
racial bigot now this is the greatest
evidence that they've got nothing on
Russian collusion if they've got Donald
Trump if they've got evidence that
Donald Trump conspired with the
government of Russia to fix the 2016
election broke presumably untold numbers
of laws made him made him itself a
traitor to his own country why would
they bring up that he doesn't like black
people it doesn't that seem a little
weak I mean you've got you've got the
President of the United States
committing treason that's the allegation
and also he said a mean thing about a
black person one time no the the reason
that they're going and trying to portray
Donald Trump is some sort of racial
bigot is because they don't have
evidence of any crime and racial bigotry
is not a crime but in the court of
public opinion it hurts him when you're
looking at the 2020 election which is
what this is really all about it hurts
him and so he says Michael Cohen goes
does the little dance that the Democrats
want him to do he says Donald Trump's a
racist mr. Trump is a racist the country
has seen mr. Trump court white
supremists and bigots
you have heard him call poorer countries
balls his private in private he is even
worse he once asked me if I can name a
country run by a black person that
wasn't a ball this was when Barack Obama
was president of the United States and
while we were once driving through a
struggling neighborhood in Chicago he
commented that only black people could
live that way and he told me that black
people would never vote for him because
they were too stupid and yet I continued
to work for him Wow oh gosh Michael
Cohen must be a pretty bad guy if he's
gonna not only work for someone like
that but he's gonna pledge undying
fealty to him say he'd take a bullet for
him Wow Michael Cohen must be a real
dirtbag
well we already knew that but in the
stories that that Michael Cohen is
telling the stories are hard to believe
heart is certainly impossible to
corroborate but then even the
insinuations he's making or bizarre
we'll get to that in a second but first
select quote you know I love select
quote if you have a mortgage you got a
family who depends on your income then
you've got to protect the ones that you
love with a life insurance life
insurance can pay off a mortgage or help
send the kids to college it's peace of
mind think you can't afford it chances
are a select quote can help you get it
for less than a dollar a day I don't do
many responsible things I'm an
irresponsible fellow you know I mean I'm
just out here hanging out with the guys
at the Daily wire all day long the one
responsible thing I've done since I got
married was get life insurance it's very
important you don't want to leave your
loved ones in a lurch so I quote
comparison shops up to 10 highly rated
companies including Prudential banner
life and Mutual of Omaha and others to
find you the company with the best rates
selectquote could find a 35 year old man
a half million dollar policy for under
$19 a month or a 37 year old female a
three quarters of a million dollar
policy for under $22 a month that's less
than a dollar a day a cup of coffee
costs more than that and out here in
la-la land a cup of coffee costs like
five times that select rewards
breakthrough techno
allows them to quickly match with the
best insurance and find your best policy
plus the quotes are free it's a great
option because they comparison shop and
save you time select quote could save
you time and money so get your free
quote at select quote comm slash Knowles
Kane or wles do it selectquote comm
slash Knowles KO wles for your free
quote don't put off protecting your
family another day select quote calm
slash Knowles get full details on the
example policy it's electric rope calm
slash Knowles your premium could vary
depending on your health issuing company
and other factors not available in all
states as that I tried to do it really
fast like all those disclaimers do and
that Kim I got a good get a little
faster Michael Cohen says Donald Trump
is this big racial bigot ok raises some
questions as to why he would keep
working for that guy but then he says
Donald Trump referred to poor countries
as [ __ ]
hella call it hellholes that's similar
to the word he used now I think Trump
was specifically referring to Haiti
where no one would deny people live in
squalor they people cook mud pies not
the delicious dessert but actual like
Mud Pie made of mud but pie they cook
mud just to fill their bellies because
people are starving there because it's a
horrific Lee run country that's not
racist
that's not racially bigoted to say that
then he says yeah Trump he said that
black people would never vote for me
well I don't know Trump's made black
support a key part of his entire
administration he constantly touts his
support among black people
he has touted black unemployment very
very low unemployment numbers as key
accomplishment of his administration he
frequently says he's done more for black
Americans than any president in American
history and it's and it's hard to refute
that now the question of the racism as
Michael Cohen's throwing spaghetti at
the wall gets challenged by Mark Meadows
who does a very good job of it mr. Cohen
do you know Lynn Patton I'm right here
oh yes sir do you know Lynn Patton yes I
do
I asked Lindy to come today in her
personal capacity to actually shed some
light how long have you known this
patent I'm responsible for Lin patent
joining the Trump Organization and the
job that she currently holds well that's
I'm glad you acknowledged that because
you made some very demeaning comments
about the the president that Miss Patten
doesn't agree with in fact it has to do
with your claim of racism
she says that as a daughter of a man
born in Birmingham Alabama that there is
no way that she would work for it for an
individual who was racist how do you
reconcile the two of those as neither
should I as the son of a Holocaust
survivor come again what was that John
Kasich is that you talking about your
father who's a mailman what does that
have to do with anything what just
happened is Michael Cohen got the
squeeze put on him said that Donald
Trump used to say Donald Trump doesn't
have a bigoted bone in his body is the
nicest most wonderful guy in the world
now he's gonna go to prison he's trying
to get out of jail and early and he says
Donald Trump is a big racist so then a
black employee of President Trump comes
in and says no he's not he's not a
racist I wouldn't work for a racist he's
fine good guy and then Michael Cohen
says Mike my father was in the Holocaust
he survived the Holocaust does that have
to do with anything because you have no
answer that's what it has to do with it
and then some meadows mark Meadows
Republican congressman presses this a
little bit further Mark Meadows in Jim
Jordan were the two real stars of this
hearing on the Republican side they
really drilled down to what matters mark
Meadows says okay you're calling him a
racist we've got a black employee of the
trumpet organization who says he's not a
racist you a schmuck who's got the
squeeze put on him who's a convicted
liar say he is a racist do you have any
evidence at all any way to corroborate
your claims that he's a racist but mr.
Cohen I guess what I'm saying is I've
talked to the president over 300 times
I've not heard one time a racist comment
out of out of his mouth in private so
how do you reconcile it do you have
proof of those conversations I would ask
you to tape recordings of those
conversations no sir
well you've taped everybody else when
yes also not true sir
that's not true you haven't taped
anybody I have taped in how many times
have you taped individuals maybe a
hundred times over ten years is that a
low estimate because I've heard it's
over 200 times Oh devastating you see
what Cohen's doing here he's trying to
play the hapless schmuck in a sense he
is a hapless schmuck but he using his
free will deceived people taped people
lied to Congress cheated the government
he did this he made those choices he
says Trump was a horrible racist he kept
working for him for a long time now he
saw no sir no yes sir no sir
in what Mark Meadows is showing is you
actually secretly record people a lot
don't you
you wouldn't know only about I don't
only like a hundred times or something
100 times have you ever have you ever
recorded a hundred conversations in your
life private conversations no it was at
200 well I mean I know so well you got
this guy who's so deceitful that he's
recording over a hundred private
conversations but he didn't he just
didn't get any of those racist ones
shucks that's too bad
that's if only he had well too bad ok so
this was a pretty brutal two-pronged
attack because it what it does is not
only totally undercuts the claims that
Cowan is making but it also portrays co
and not as this pitiful little schmuck
but as a political operative who is now
switching sides and doing exactly the
same hard-charging flacking that he used
to do for Trump now he's doing it for
the Democrats
Omarosa tried this too she said I've got
tapes of Donald Trump saying terribly
bigoted things say okay show them well
no well no no no I don't want to now she
said all of this while she was trying to
sell her book so okay I remember that I
got the tapes I'm coming out with the
tapes all right well she's not selling
her book anymore where's the tapes
they're not coming out so the GOP
pointing out inconsistencies even within
that the testimony today you've got
Michael Cohen convicted of lying you've
got every little line he comes out with
the GOP seems to counter and then he
contradicts himself probably lies again
before Congress certainly lies again
before Congress the best Cohen can come
up with at the very end is grade school
taunts you're a pathological
pathological liar
you don't know truth from from trip from
falsehood sir I'm sorry are you it's my
time are you from answer when I ask you
a question I'll ask for an answer sure
Paul your you referring to me or the
president haha
I am rubber and you are glue yeah
whatever whatever you it bounces off of
me it sticks to you hey yeah yeah I went
to law school yeah alright
it's like devolved into Rodney danger to
get no respect i ye know y'all know my
doctor dr. vinny boombots yeah so this
is basically the best coming can come up
when you see this little sly smile yeah
yeah he you're talking about the
president yeah yeah that's all this is
this is just stupid sophomoric
insinuation that gets shot down on every
factual point by the GOP we will talk
about what it all means
what the main takeaway is we got a lot
more to get to but first go to daily
wire calm you know what you get you get
all the shows you get to ask questions
in the mail back coming up tomorrow you
get everything and you get the Michael
Cohen the sort of the leftist tears
tumblr you get the leftist to your stump
or get it or you're gonna drown go to
daily wire calm we'll be right back
okay pathetic showing from Cohen
grade-school taunt is the best he can
come what basically that's all you can
walk away with because all of the claims
he makes get refuted he that he himself
contradicts them so all you gather these
grade school taunts and you realized
that this tool is dancing for Democrats
the same way he used to dance for Trump
my main personal takeaway from this was
looking at this I thought of the
heavenly virtues prudence justice
temperance fortitude faith hope and
charity and I thought through all of the
characters of history have you ever
encountered a person with such an abject
emptiness a total lack of those all of
those virtues as Michael Cohen obviously
there are a lot worse people in history
much more wicked people much more unjust
people sure but when you think about
them in history go to a Atilla the Hun
or something at least they had fortitude
at least they I don't know at least they
had hope either they had Michael Cohen
has he doesn't have prudence
he's been reckless his whole career
reckless working for Trump now reckless
working for the Democrats justice what
justice he lies out of both corners of
his mouth
temperance he doesn't seem like a
temperate may doesn't seem like a
terribly moderate man he's all about
extremes fortitude is totally weak he
admits he says I'm a weakling my
weakness has led me to where I am today
faith and not a lot of fidelity with
that guy hope not a lot of hope he knows
he's going to jail charity no charity at
all he's willing to betray his
benefactors he's just bereft of any of
the virtues how sad for him broadly when
you look at the political takeaways from
the hearings it turns up nothing of
substance what of substance came out of
this Trump lawyer says Trump is a racist
and then Trump black employee says he's
not okay Trump says
Herr Cohen says that Trump paid off
stormy Daniels uh-huh got it we have we
knew that one Cohen says I Trump's a bad
guy okay right we got that all it does
is create a distraction and there is an
actual scandal here we know that the
Democrats in the Hillary Clinton
campaign colluded with the Obama Justice
Department and a foreign intelligence
source that goes all the way into Russia
and the evidence that we have of this is
the steel dossier we know you have FBI
agents fired and disgrace Andrew McCabe
admitting that he tried to launch a coup
d'etat commit treason to overturn a
presidential election Peter struck top
FBI agent saying that the FBI the power
of the state would not allow Donald
Trump to be elected president colluding
with Democrats Democrat funded foreign
intelligence to spy on the Trump
campaign try to stop them from winning
that is the scandal and we're going to
hear about that scandal as it comes out
Jim Jordan gets it Jim Jordan Republican
congressman talks about the actual
scandal here in in beautiful and concise
detail I want you to think about this
when have you ever seen a federal agency
where this has happened James Comey
director fired
Andy McCabe deputy director fired live
three times under oath under
investigation right as we speak Jim
Baker FBI Council demoted then left
currently under investigation by the US
Attorney's Office in Connecticut Lisa
page demoted then left Peter struck
deputy head of counterintelligence
demoted then fired that's what happened
that's what we're concerned about so
you've got two competing scandals Trump
colluded with Russia the Democrats
colluded with the DOJ and actually
Russia foreign intelligence those are
the two competing scandals and they're
both trying to get airtime the way that
you know that the Democrat scandal is
illegitimate and that the Republican or
the Democrat allegations rather are
illegitimate Democrat scandal is very
legitimate and that the Republican
claims are legitimate that the real
scandal here was perpetrated by the
Democrats the way that you know that
that the GOP is on the right track
is that our allegation hasn't changed
our allegation is the Democrats colluded
with the Obama Justice Department which
colluded with foreign intelligence to
subvert the 2016 election to spy on the
Trump campaign and to try to overturn at
once Trump won
that's our allegation there's a lot of
evidence for that the Democrats story
what is the Democrats story the
Democrats story is Trump never wanted to
win he was only enriching himself
personally also Trump so totally wanted
to win that he was willing to commit
crimes with a foreign government to
cheat and rigged the election then the
other then Trump slept with a porn star
that's four somehow that's part of this
scandal too he slept with a porn star
and also he's a racist there's no
evidence of that but he's a racist
that's that's the so you've got not only
contradictions without the Democrat
within the Democrat games
you've got totally irrelevant insults
and charges Trump is a racist first of
all first of all especially after Spike
Lee's stupid speech at the Oscars there
are many photos on the internet the
internet is forever there are many
photos of Donald Trump paddling around
with Spike Lee palying around without
Sharpton winning awards with Muhammad
Ali and Rosa Parks nobody ever called
this man a racist until he ran for
president is a Republican but that
they're throwing spaghetti at the wall
because they don't have real charges and
furthermore because they're guilty of a
major scandal themselves the left always
projects and what are they guilty
they're guilty of interfering the 2016
election conspiring and colluding with
the federal government and with foreign
governments to prevent Donald Trump from
becoming president what is the political
fallout from this testimony nothing
doesn't move the needle well what
evidence did Michael Cohen provide he
provided a check that Donald Trump
reimbursed him for services yep we knew
that he provided a copy of financial
statements we already knew about Michael
Cohen's complex finances and Donald
Trump's for that matter he provided an
article with Donald Trump's handwriting
that possibly implied that Trump
use nonprofit money on a portrait for
one of his clubs sir side does that
sound confusing or irrelevant yeah I did
I mean if the charge is that Donald
Trump misused some nonprofit money great
great I can't wait for us to litigate
that one in the court of public opinion
when the Clinton family took money
hand-over-fist
millions and millions and millions of
dollars from foreign governments while
Hillary Clinton was Secretary of State
in their slush fund foundation which had
to be shut down it was so corrupt great
bring that one on okay perfect and then
the other one the other evidence is
letters that Cohen wrote on behalf of
Trump to the College Board which runs
the SATs to high schools to colleges to
prevent them and intimidate them from
releasing Trump's grades and SAT scores
which they shouldn't do anyway this is
evidence that of what I don't what is
that evidence anybody would do that
Hillary Clinton would always kept her
thesis from Wellesley College under lock
and key what does that prove at all like
what he's trying to imply he's not
trying to show any crime or any
nefarious activity what he's trying to
imply as the Trump is an idiot that he
has low SAT scores low grades which is
really rich coming from Michael Cohen
who attended according to above the law
of law school rankings the worst law
school in the country Michael Cohen
attended a law school with the highest
admission percentage of any American Bar
Association approved law school this was
a major issue they basically let in
anybody who applied the median LSAT
score of people who went to Michael
Cohen's law school was in the 18th
percentile which we're seeing today as
this clown is running his mouth before
Congress seventy percent of graduates of
that law school could not get a law job
full time law job within nine months of
graduation the vast majority and here is
Michael Cohen implying that Donald Trump
is an idiot a billionaire who went to
Wharton okay right good that's cute so
even the insinuations but there's no
real fallout now the practical side of
this dem
gratz we use this as an excuse to launch
more investigations more hearings more
what if they were gonna do that anyway
there's no bombshells that came out of
this it doesn't change anybody's opinion
okay now this is obviously frustrating
and so much as it takes away a news
cycle news cycle where we could be
talking about Donald Trump meeting with
Kim jong-un a new cycle where we could
be talking about how the left is
defending dictators in Venezuela where
we could be talking about how the left
is defending infanticide that's okay
they got their news cycle out of it good
for them
good for them what does this do I don't
think it accomplishes what they wanted
it to I think that we're hoping for that
bombshell I think debbie Wasserman
Schultz was hoping she would say how do
you corroborate this and Cohen would say
here's how I do it but he saw huh all
right yeah I went to a law school that
basically isn't even a law school what
do you expect me to do huh ah you all
know my doctor doctor Vinny boombots
basically a loss for Democrats I mean
it's sort of whatever we presented
unsavory things that an unsavory news
stories that were already out there to
begin with
I do it before we go today I do want to
show this clip because I think I'm
getting the weather reports from hell
and it's pretty chilly down there today
Jorge Ramos far left winger he's the guy
on Univision who's a grandstanding
buffoon who hates Donald Trump a total
partisan hack he went on Sean Hannity's
show just the other day because Jorge
Ramos was down in Venezuela left winger
and that socialist dictatorship down
there detained him they threatened him
and it just reminds me socialism is to
the left at least it sounds great on a
sunny day in Manhattan oh it sounds
wonderful so fair so wonderful then the
reality of it really hurts even for a
far left winger like Jorge Ramos who you
would never expect ever to say a nice
thing about someone like Sean Hannity or
any conservative when he saw the reality
of socialism when he was detained by a
socialist government when his life was
threatened by a socialist government he
goes on Sean Hannity's show too
his praises when I needed that support
the most I heard that you were talking
about us in Venezuela and that was
incredibly important so from the bottom
of my heart thank you so much Shawn
thanks so much to Fox News because and
on those moments when you are detained
in a dictatorship when there's no one to
help you and you see a tweet or you see
a report from Fox News or from an
American media you know that you're not
alone and we felt that we were not alone
so muchas gracias
a chilly day in hell but there is jorge
ramos thanking conservatives for
defending him against the socialist
regime in venezuela he then went on
anderson cooper show on a left-wing show
to talk about what happened to him down
there venezuelan agents were outside a
hotel the whole night so nobody could
come in and we we couldn't we couldn't
leave the airport they wanted to make
sure that we were going to go directly
to the airport we were deported actually
from from Venezuela he was it was it was
a difficult moment because we didn't
know what what could happen it's a
dictatorship so they can do anything
they want and we were concerned that at
the airport at some point during our
journey that they could have the
kidnapped us or kept us in the country
without our permission obviously an
Democrats are still defending them
defending socialism defending that
radicalism they're defending Maduro
Bernie Sanders won't call Maduro a
dictator Jorge Ramos will they're
defending socialism they're running on
socialism they're running on radicalism
we're at a time so we can't get to some
of the more radical suggestions that
they now have but that's what they're
running on that's what they're this is
all about 2020 and they're looking at
2020 and they're running on pretty
unpopular things open borders
infanticide socialism which has caused a
dictatorship and starvation in the
streets in Venezuela a formerly rich
country they're running on all these
unpopular things and the only thing that
they can do to distract from it is throw
a bunch of circuses and try to convince
people that Donald Trump is a racist
bigot who never wanted to be President
he really wanted to be President he'd do
anything and he committed crimes and
there's a Bob
that's all they can do is create a crazy
distraction but the reality underneath
is the corruption and the radicalism of
the Democrat Party which unfortunately
for them it's a long haul to 2020 there
gonna be a lot of debates and they're
not going to be able to hide it for very
long they can't they can't hide it
behind Fredo
Michael Cohen for very long that's our
show come back to mortgage mailbag
questions and in the meantime I'm
Michael nose this is the Michael Nolt
show I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19